it's just shazam day at comic-con we're
gonna do another video following up to
talk about something else that's a
little
that everyone's really excited a little
disappointing we'll talk about that
definitely happened and it took place
today
but we got a black adam trailer as we
expected so john greg
andrew greg citizens of the reject
nation leave a like shazam that like
button also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified for
whatever else we cover for the day of
comic con
now let's see this black adam trent
[Music]
my powers
are not a gift
oh what a curse
this movie does look beautiful
got some of that
nice
the world needed a hero
instead it got me
god damn it
good damn it hawk man
i'm so excited to see noah sentinel
i'm not gonna lie it's not my life
i do find that man a very charming actor
that i know has sent to neo yeah that
was a cool trailer cool little tease
that we got here i'm looking forward to
this film i was rewatching the first
trailer yesterday i've been looking up
on black adam looking up at black adam
that's what i've been doing all of us
are yeah i've been uh i've been
researching on black adam he keeps
saying that in these trailers that he's
he's gonna be a villain but it seems
pretty obvious that by the end of this
film black adam's definitely gonna be a
hero what i was looking apparently in
this film like the justice society of
america they are no longer formed so you
got like people here who are linked to
it in a lot everyone here is like linked
to it in some way hawkman and you know
uh
dr fate
adam smasher cyclone cyclone yes we all
got a name we all did it we all did it
we successfully named all of the justice
society of american characters yeah so
there's like a history here with hawkman
i think there's like a lineage
connection here from who um black adam
was before he was awakened like back in
the ancient times in this timeline there
is some type of lineage connection so i
don't know the full details of what's
expected to come exactly out of it i
imagine that they're also setting up to
get a justice society of america movie
then by the end of this movie they will
eventually decide
yeah
yeah so i'm kind of curious how they're
going to handle black adam's arc in this
film because clearly you're going to see
the past of when given the shazam powers
when he was wronged then he wakes up in
present time not sure what his goal is
what time is it to get revenge just to
take it out on everything is it to
dominate the world is it the free
conduct so yeah i i i don't know exactly
what his his motive is here but it seems
like from watching the first trailer
watching this the things i read up on
about this movie the research i've done
on black adam i'm probably gonna fight
with him at first and then by the end
he's gonna be working with them right
now it just seems like that's the
trajectory of the film yeah but i like
that they're not going with the bvs
trailer approach where it's they show
you yeah exactly it's like you you set
up the match up and i actually
even though this is a short kind of
tease i do kind of prefer this look at
it because it started to hit me of how
kind of cool this seems that their
approach is to yeah you have the central
figure of dwayne johnson as black adam
and yeah he brings this menace of an
anti-hero of somebody who would have
villainous intent at the start and then
you have this group and i was sitting
here going i'm actually really
fascinated to see how these you know jsa
members you know come together to face
this how we meet them through this
experience and then yeah what the
ultimate evolution how they'll handle
the theme is there when dr fate's saying
you know like you don't necessarily have
to be you know a destroyer in this place
and and the one big thing that i'm i
imagine would happen and i'm looking
forward to is i feel like dwayne johnson
loves a good like buddy character to
play off and i know in the comics there
is you know certain takes where him and
adam smasher do sort of buddy up and i
feel like him and noah centennial
together centennial however you say that
guy's name i feel like them together
might become a very charming duo uh
later on down the line while still
keeping some of that edge so i i was
really into this uh maybe more so uh
than the first trailer yeah i mean this
looks intriguing and i know the draw to
this is black adam and seeing the jsa uh
but specifically for me the thing i'm
looking most forward to is dr fate
pierce brosnan playing this character i
mean the character design looks
absolutely incredible i mean my last
recollection of seeing the character at
least on the small screen i could be
wrong but was in smallville i know
that's everyone's favorite
uh i didn't feel the character was done
too much justice in that show no pun
intended but i'm i'm looking forward to
how pierce brosnan is going to interpret
the character and again just the
character design and just the small
little glimpses what we're seeing here
just looks really interesting i think i
was reading up that they were talking
possibly with liam neeson about doing
this role but i think pierce brosnan
just from what we've seen yeah he's
pretty pretty damn good casting i mean
i'm just curious if he's going to order
a vodka martini by the end of him not
stirred but i know getting uh but
getting back to the rock i mean he just
you can tell he's got such a love for
this character and i'm really hoping at
some point i know we got a little
disappointed which we're going to talk
about in the next video about uh certain
news today but i'm hoping at some point
there's some kind of a tease or
something there in regards to superman
because i i really want to see henry
cavill's superman go up against black uh
dwayne johnson's black adam at some
point i mean that's just beyond epic if
we could get that at some point comic
fans or even like video game fans or or
animated movie fan like it doesn't
matter the animated movies are usually
based on the comics so yeah
like directly so yeah like i would
definitely want that too i like dwayne
johnson said that he's never connected
to a character
more than ever and i'm like really i
don't how i'm not sure maybe because he
felt like wronged or something and he
felt like he had to prove himself and
then through aggression
learned
well when the wizard knifed
like powers after his family was killed
and he joined the wwe you know i'm just
very similar
i was just so curious to know what he
meant by that because yeah he seems like
he's a super aggressive character in the
beginning who will then learn to be
some form i don't have the right word
soft maybe like compassionate or
something well it seems like you know at
least here and two not that this is
gonna have like a million tie overs with
shazam fury the guys but you know like
there's gotta be a black adam and shazam
clash and there is more godly presence
dc movies up until now have treated
their characters like gods but this one
this new phase seems like it's actually
bringing in a lot of gods and god-like
powers and things like that and i feel
like you know
with his origin there's a certain amount
of vendetta there too and then everybody
else down below that so maybe it's it's
got to do with that kind of taking on
the powers that be because it's an
unfair unjust universe and then learning
oh wait a minute maybe there are
just and uh you know applications of
this power that suit a grayer harsher
world that don't have to be pure
villainy all right guys well here we are
black adam leave your thoughts down
below and what you think about the
trailer what you think is going to
happen in this movie do you want to see
black adam versus zachary levi first or
henry cavill
all right see you guys soon